let's not waste too much time
um as we as we go through here you guys
know we've done we've done the pop-ins
and one that made it most popular most
famous was the one the only from legal
af podcast
michael popock with the po poc poppin
michael pobach how are you sir
i'm doing great why why is my camera so
dark i don't know
i don't know
yeah tony i'm doing great so so i i have
a lot of questions for you we wanted i i
text you yesterday and i said hey this
manhattan d.a thing is is in the news
it's crazy um so i had a lot of
questions about
the manhattan da's
um what's going on in that office
because it seems like there's a lot of
drama going on
if that's fair to say
so let's start from the top the
manhattan d.a opened up a criminal
investigation into the trump
organization correct
yeah they did both they did they did two
things
they worked in conjunction with the
um new york attorney general latisha
james's office which is on the civil
side correct work working in conjunction
with the manhattan district attorney's
office
which was originally sy vance who was
retired and then now alvin bragg since
january 1st and they were working for
the last year and a half
overlapping in conjunction
people from the manhattan da's office
working closely with the
civil lawyers at the new york attorney
general's office
and we know what leticia james has been
doing because she has been filing in
court
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
pages
that explain where she is in the various
fraud civil fraud investigations
that she has
been conducting
issues but that's very typical for a
civil right to file that many documents
in court is that is that very typical
well not exactly i think she's been more
conscientious about the documentation
that she has filed to both justify the
investigation
and to respond through the court system
to the media blitz that the trumps and
the trumplets and all the trumpers you
know all his tweets and she feels
compelled and i don't blame her to put
to put together a shed load of material
and that's a legal term and file it not
a shitload of [ __ ] no shed
i would i would say shitload but you
know a shitload of material that's right
and you know
you don't know all the internal
confidential investigatory methods she's
using right but you know the results
that they're focused on the financial
statements that they're focused on um
improper fraudulent inflation of his
assets deflation of his assets in order
to secure tax abatements inflation of
his assets in order to borrow money
that's all front and center and she's
about to get the deposition of donald
trump and of uh donald jr anna vavanka
because
the new york superior sorry supreme
court justice that's responsible for
this has ordered that they appear now
he's taken a
uh trump has taken an appeal to the
first department first level appeal here
in manhattan
and he's going to lose that and he's
going to have to sit for a deposition
now that's everything related to the new
york
um attorney general who sits in albany
at in our state capitol and that's the
civil side of it not the case it's a
civil side she hasn't been conducting a
criminal side and
trump wants her to conduct a criminal
side because then he'll take you know he
wants her to drag him into the grand
jury but she's not conducting the grand
jury manhattan district attorney's
office which is for most people
understand that's been the model for
every law and order episode is based on
the manhattan district attorney's office
we had a change in guard at the
manhattan da's office so who was who was
who was the original d.a that opened
this case cyrus vance okay who comes
from a long well-considered political
family
um starting with his father and cybants
you know people have their own problems
with cybants but i always thought that
psy
was on the right side of justice and he
opened the in the criminal investigation
he hired
mark pomerance
who's the special prosecutor i'm going
to talk about with you next who resigned
in february he hired the other there
were two special prosecutors mark
pomerantz was 70 and came out of
retirement to do this full-time for a
year and a half with sci vance
sai vance
allowed them to develop their evidence
working with special investigators
talk to witnesses and open up a special
grand jury in order to present the
evidence to get an indictment
right at the moment
where
they weren't really ready to go into the
grand jury yet for the full indictment
they had witnesses going into the grand
jury the the the um time period for the
grand jury expired
sy vance extended it knowing that he'd
be leaving office in january to give the
new sheriff in town the new
uh attorney
manhattan district attorney alvin bragg
time to make his own prosecutorial
decision about whether to continue
because when you inherit a prosecution
fundamentally you still have to make
your own decision as to whether you
because the buck stops with you whether
you are going to prosecute that case so
so what you're saying is is that science
couldn't force uh alvin bragg who is the
new d.a to prosecute in other words once
that once the the sword is passed uh you
know now it is bragg's sword in other
words one thou you got it exactly right
the only other
wild hair here wild card here
is that there is one other person
that can influence a prosecution and a
prosecutorial decision other than the
d.a in a way other than the d.a and that
is
the person that's sitting behind the
plaque that says governor of the state
of new york oh okay so cat so so kathy
ho cool who's our
uh act she's not even acting she's our
she's our governor of new york she's
running she's running for election
she has already been apprised of this
she has the right to replace
attorney generals uh um and and
manhattan and district attorneys for the
different counties
she can so what you're saying what's the
way you're saying is she can just she
can just pull a mulligan on bragg
she can do one of two things she can
she's already met with him about the
case that's been reported in the media
gotcha she can give him a warning and
say
tell me
present the case to me i want to
understand the case
if the governor says alvin with all due
respect you should be prosecuting this
case and you should be bringing this to
the grand jury and alvin says i don't
want to
she has two choices
she can either replace him meaning she
takes away the will of the people
because he was elected with a very high
percentage by the people of the city of
of new york in manhattan to be the d.a
there
she can say i'm going to replace you on
this case and i'm going to assign a new
prosecutor in a new county to handle the
case because i don't think you're doing
your job or i could fire you and he
knows that he's he's been told and sh
and it's been reported in the media
that when when somebody interviewed her
three weeks ago and said well
governor you have the power to remove
the prosecutor right if you don't like
the job they're doing and her response
was very diplomatic but very chilling
she said i am well aware
of the powers of the governor
uh if you're alvin bragg that's not a
great right you know that's like an
owner of an nfl team about a coach you
know when they say well the coach's
record is terrible are you going to keep
them i'm well aware of my powers as the
owner of the team
i know i know his record and i know i
know that i can fire that person right
so so
but now alvin here's some let me
wrap it up quick here because you want
to get to mark pomerantz
february the 23rd there was a bombshell
in the trump
investigative criminal investigation
through the manhattan da's office in
that the two special prosecutors who
were deputized by al by sci vance and
inherited by alvin bragg
and they didn't just resign quietly they
resigned noisily
they did not release their resignation
letter they did not leak their
resignation right which i have part of
it that i'll show here
well it's fit the new york times has a
copy of it not from pomeranz but has a
copy of it and ran with the story last
night we suspected so karen uh friedman
agnifilo my other co-anchor on legal af
midweek who worked as the number two
underside vance in the manhattan da's
office we did a whole
twitter spaces back on february 23rd
when this bombshell came out where we
were shadow boxing and speculating a
little bit about what that letter of
resignation said but we said what what
has happened which it was the death
knell for the prosecution
no matter what alvin bragg said three
days after the resignations where he
said no no i'm not killing the
prosecution i'm reassigning it to some
career prosecutors in our office and
we're still on the case nobody really
believes that everybody believes that if
pomeranz had walked out the door we
didn't know exactly why on that day it
was for some really good reason where
they had crossed the line of his moral
and professional
um uh boundaries and he decided he
couldn't take it anymore and left now
we've gotten the letter i don't know if
you want to put up a little bit yeah or
read from it yeah let's see if we can um
let me pull this down here
this is this is from pomerantz now who
who is mark pomerance so the audience is
clear on this so mark mark pomerantz is
a supremely well respected sort of a
lion of the bar in the in the city of
new york has been for the last 40 years
he is a white collar criminal defense
guru former prosecutor
a short list if you if you ever need i
sound like i'm doing an ad for mark
pomerance all right
short list if you ever got in trouble
with the federal or state government on
a prosecutorial side and needed a lawyer
by your side mark pomerance would be on
your list he would he can't he was
retired he came out of retirement
because sai vance asked him to take on
this very important role of being the
lead prosecutor in the office for trump
so you know we thought when mark
pomerance came on the case that was
terrible news for trump because pomeranz
is a pitbull and he's known about it now
there's one other interesting link the
media sort of glossed over but i'm gonna
break it here on your show you ready
[ __ ] em tony yeah i'm i'm ready let's
break it so so ron fascetti who is the
lawyer for donald trump donald trump and
who constantly
tweets out like trump about there's no
merit to the case there's no merit to
the case why are they prosecuting this
he was a law partner of pomeranz about
20 25 years ago so these two they know
each other they know each other really
well they were law partners i don't know
why they're no longer law partners but
they but they're law partners so they're
these two lions sort of you know
fighting it out over here um but um i
think that you want to put the letter
back up yeah yeah you want to quote from
part of it about
because this is i want to tell your your
listeners and followers this is not
normal it is not normal for the
prosecutor to put in his departing
resignation letter that he believes
there is sufficient evidence why why is
that not normal why is that normal a
prosecutors don't resign in protest
because their cases aren't being
prosecuted and when that happens they
don't write detailed letters that
because they don't become evidence one
day that'll be used with the defense so
what you're saying is this is possible
evident we're looking at possible
evidence that could be used in the
trials what you're saying well no but
it'll be used by for shetty to argue to
a judge that the case either has no
merit or that that there's pomerantz has
some sort of axe to grind i see it it'll
be used against the prosecution which is
why prosecutors don't usually write it i
think pomerance wrote it
a he's no dummy he knows it was going to
leak out at some point i don't think he
did it but certainly one degree or two
degrees move from mark pomerance he sort
of looked the other way and let it get
out to the new york times why is it
because it's because it hasn't leaked
for several weeks though i mean like for
a month right right
for a full month but here it says quite
clearly
donald trump has committed crimes under
the new york penal law related to his
financial dealings i as a prosecutor
believe that we can make out beyond a
reasonable doubt that he is guilty of
crimes he needs to be prosecuted and
alvin bragg your decision with all due
respect you know what comes next when
somebody says with all due respect with
all due respect alvin your good faith
belief that there's not enough evidence
to support this prosecution you're wrong
and this case should be prosecuted and i
am resigning in protest as it says here
i therefore resign effective immediately
good luck to you alvin and i think this
is now leaked with that and the governor
issue that we just talked about is going
to put pressure on alvin bragg to to
to do something about prosecuting trump
but then
what's for shetty going to say the trump
prosecutor the trump defense lawyer oh
this is political this is because he got
pressure because the new york times
article judge this whole thing is a
charade it should be dismissed so will
that make a big difference though will
that make a big difference it could
and who who will that make a difference
too to a judge or judge right and what
what step is that because we're not
talking about going straight to a jury
and you know them having this this this
charade it would go to a judge first
right i mean yeah which would make some
of those differences first there's
exactly right tony there's two ways to
do it and the one way i don't think will
be that successful because they've tried
it before where they file a motion
for injunction to stay the continued
investigation and prosecution even
though there's been no indictment so
pre-indictment they go run into this
judge and say judge look at this look at
the circus that's been created by mark
parmerance and and this letter and the
new york times article the whole thing
should be dismissed and you should stop
issuing injunction to stop the manhattan
da's office from going any further in
the investigation i don't think that's
going to work but
what will happen is if alvin bragg now
you know to continue our inappropriate
sports analogies and metaphors starts
hearing footsteps
and decides maybe i should prosecute
this case and and brings it to the grand
jury with the new prosecutor because
pomeranz is out never coming back this
was napalm on the bridge he's never
coming back to that office which his
work was his work stays though right i
mean all the work yeah yeah yeah yeah
but he'll never come back right he'll
he'll never come back to this situation
no because of this letter that he's
written so let's say that so this is
step two this is uh scenario two they
they go with the new prosecutor they
bring the full evidence now they make
the presentation and they get the grand
jury to indict which frankly
they're going to be able to get an
indictment there's an old joke about any
prosecutor worth his salt could indict a
ham sandwich and that's kind of what
pomerantz might be saying is that what
he's saying here or is he going way
beyond yeah give it to me let me get let
me in coach i can get an indictment with
the grand jury why are you hesitating
why are you pausing and and alvin
unfortunately he was a popular pick
in the when he was elected but he's just
done terrible he's shown terrible
terrible
political judgment and professional
judgment since january it started with
his first day memo which he sent out and
said people were all able to interpret
as i'm gonna be light on crime which is
a terrible
you got mayor adams who just got elected
on i'm gonna be tough on crime i'm a
former a former cop and i need to clean
up the city i got to be batman
and then you have the d.a uh heart that
the harvey dent as it were not the
hardest not not being the harvey dent
right right right i mean when did i move
to gotham i didn't realize that
right so that was a terrible and that
literally was on his first day and he's
gone downhill ever since and now you got
the governor who's got to worry about
her own political fortunes because she's
a democrat even though she's a
conservative democrat and i think she's
going to have another her chief of
staff's going to call another meeting
with alvin brack after this new york
times article we may or may not hear
about that meeting but i think we will
and then we got to worry that if they
get the indictment it's been so
dented and scratched that when it goes
before a judge
it's going to give for shetty mileage to
argue that the whole thing should be
thrown out on a motion to dismiss
well and and and i want to i want to add
one more thing to this letter and i
don't know if pomerantz knows this or
not about our show but he really should
have added at the end of this letter
[ __ ] him you know i i'm just i'm just
saying that maybe maybe we could uh you
know scratch that in here and make a
graphic here where it says [ __ ] them
because that's basically what he's
saying
in this letter is like look you have the
evidence he's done crime it's clear-cut
all of our work shows this
we will be able to not only not only
slam dunk this i mean he wouldn't uh
basically write this letter because my
understanding is is when a when a
prosecutor
which he is the special assistant
district attorney here in this letter
that's his title um
when i when a prosecutor leaves like
this they do not write letters where
they're like there's evidence there's a
crime and the reason why i'm i'm leaving
is because there's a crime normally it's
like some kind of you know
soft-handed oh well thanks for having me
but i've got you know i need to spend
more time i need to spend more time with
my family i'm going on vacation whatever
whatever the hell it is no he went and
just to continue our legal af uh overlap
um a crossover episode here he's gone
even further tony he's not saying
i know i would have gotten the
indictment in front of the grand jury
which is not on the same standard as
having to prove your case it's not
beyond a reasonable doubt
it's it's a different it's a lower
standard of evidence proof when you're
just getting the indictment he's saying
not only would i get the indictment but
if i tried this case in front of a jury
it is beyond a reasonable doubt that
criminal felonies have been committed by
the former president of the united
states and you're not letting me do my
job yeah that's what this letter says
well that because the first quote on
this part of the letter i fear that your
decision which he's talking to brag
means that mr trump will not be held
fully
accountable for his crimes meaning and
and that's the that's what you're saying
is he's saying here he will he can be
held fully accountable if you would just
do your [ __ ] job he calls it and he
calls it crimes he doesn't say he's not
pulling punches he's not saying uh
potential crimes uh indicted cri
indicted charges he's saying crimes
the
and you're right you normally do not say
prosecutors are usually more circumspect
more cautious
more but but not when you're leaving
when you're leaving it's like you know
what
just kick everything over let me drop my
drawers and really tell you what i feel
and and not and to your point about it
should say [ __ ] them at the end when i
was a younger lawyer starting my career
and there still were fax machines tony
do you know what a fax machine is i i
have seen one of these uh archaic things
before you know i know what a fax
machine is using okay when i was in high
school i won't even go into it it was a
roller yeah you actually rubber banded
the piece of paper around the roller and
you stuck it in a cradle okay that was
affects me but back in the day
you would write the old joke was if you
were a lawyer you would write something
like a fax a one-line fax that said [ __ ]
you letter to follow oh
oh so that's like the that's like the
intro the the cover page as it were yes
letter letter to follow right and so
that's sort of this except the letter
did follow and the new york times and
doing you know
again just to remind everybody
why we love why we enjoy democracy why
we enjoy the first amendment and the
constitution why it's so important
because it's papers like the guardian
the new york times and other
uh investigative reporting institutions
that bring these things to light that
shine sunshine on these cesspools which
will lead to look what some i don't know
exactly what it's going to be you and i
have laid out some scenarios
something is going to happen cause and
effect because the pomerantz letter was
published yesterday on the digital
version the new york times well i i
appreciate you joining us and one one
more thing before we go um how long is a
da's term when they're elected to the
manhattan da's because it seems to me
that maybe mr bragg if he does make it
through um his coach not firing or the
owner not firing the coach it does seem
that he might have a very bad chance of
winning in so how long is mr bragg's
term yeah i think it's four years right
it's not six i think it's four he's up
every four look i i followed that race
very closely he was not my choice just
so to be clear lucy lange who is now the
inspector general the office of
inspector general for the entire state
of new york selected by governor hokul
was my choice she was also in that
office
um and she came in a very very close
fourth it was it was um
ranked voting for the first time in the
in the city of new york so you got to
rank your people and she lost by you
know a handful of votes there but alvin
won alvin had a lot of support he had
the chops it's not that he's not
qualified he is qualified he's been a
state prosecutor he's been a federal
prosecutor he's worked in prosecution
most of his life and he was very well
respected
but he
he left his brass ones at the front door
when he when he crossed into the office
back to the sports analogy he whiffed on
this one let's just say that he whiffed
and and and the people have been
scratching i have to tell you people
have been scratching their head about
alvin bragg and not with joy it's not
like i'm happy that the first black
manhattan district attorney in 200 years
is not doing well i wanted him to do
well but if you have eyes and ears it's
hard to
right it's hard not to criticize the
things that he's done some of it's been
political he he's been a terrible pr
machine for himself and that means he's
not surrounding himself with the right
people who will who will guide him in
that right direction and some of it is
his own judgment i mean
he knew mark pomerance was not going to
be happy about
about ending the prosecution he knew
that mark was going to leave and
probably noisily how did he handle that
not well right well i appreciate you
joining us appreciate you giving this
breakdown of what's happening in the
manhattan da's office and everyone go
download legal af
both episodes a week there's the
wednesday episode that you do with kfa
and then the the weekend uh episode that
you do with ben mizellis uh download
that wherever you download podcast or go
to the midas touch uh youtube channel
you can watch it you can watch it there
if you wanna if you wanna watch
um the legal i wanna do a crossover
episode now that you're part of the
midas mighty yeah and a midas platform i
want to do a crossover episode where you
come on our show yeah sure i i would be
happy to come um give my uh [ __ ]
style breakdown of the law even though
i'm not you know an attorney or a lawyer
i would no but you're
i would definitely
say you're a very good what they with
what they would call you in uh in london
overseas is you're a very good presenter
oh yeah yeah well i appreciate that
which we like all right so i'm going to
uh i'm going to run but uh
this is it you you got it breaking news
we didn't even do the legal af version
of this story yet
i'll cut this out we'll try to clip it
up maybe we can get the suits over at
midas touch to put it somewhere and that
way everyone can watch everyone stick
around right after the break thanks
michael polpak we'll talk to you soon my
friend bye tony
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]